yesterday was a terrible day for
everyone who loves france and loves
paris in the lives of all of us paris
is not a neutral place
it's a place we
always love to fall in love with seeing this
city grappling with a tragedy that
is not only architectural but
which concerns the life of the French people or even
being destroyed by flames the
outward sign of the French force since
many are those who visit our
lady since always hurts the heart
yesterday a significant part of france
comes from  to be seriously injured and we
are all somewhat widowed and
so I would like to express to
our French friends
the full sympathy of the commission,
which moreover has declared itself in agreement
to support all the efforts including
France  could
need europe got hurt france
moved bets to table enough we
were seated there we stand in solidarity with
our french friends